puis en 90 quel look fourati la voie
difficile à dire quand on connaît
l'énorme succès de kathrin la chanteuse
des rita mitsouko qui a chanté tout
l'été avec une dent en moins
effectivement une chanteuse normalement
une belle dentition par tous les gens
qui présentent à la télé et c'est même
se fondre blanchir les dents ce terrain
puis moi ça m'est arrivé pendant que je
travaillais cette dent donc je n'avais
pas le temps de leur faire faire puis je
trouvais ça marrant même temps je crois
que j'avais une tronche de deux affiches
camp surtout quand je suis bien
maquillée tout ça bien belle bien coiffé
acquis hongrie hong kong les fouilles
parce que pour faire un sourire idiot je
trouvais ça marrant donc je me suis pas
précipité chez le dentiste mais je vais
y aller et sinon je vais aussi des échos
de gens pour qu'ils trouvaient ça
justement vachement bien parce que ça
donnait un côté
un peu un côté quelque chose qui merde
dans ma personne
une belle fille et tous qui chante bien
il fait des bonnes chansons d'amy
appliqué en même temps un truc qui merde